you must have heard your friends speak a  variety of different languages right but  have you ever wondered how many  languages are spoken in the world itself  there are more than 7 000 languages that  are spoken in the world and in fact more  than 700 are spoken in India itself  now some languages are more well known  than others for instance English which  is the most spoken language in the world  then you have Mandarin Chinese and our  very own Hindi these are very well-known  languages  but have you heard of this language  called busu it's a very less known  language and it is spoken only by eight  people  there is another language called Nigeria  a language spoken in Africa which is  known by only four people now this is  how big and diverse our world actually  is  now guys what is your favorite language  would love to know comment down below  and for more such amazing facts follow  don't memorize